[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Miami en
Estados Unidos con nuestro corresponsal
alto nivel si para hablar sobre la
comparecencia del expresidente Donald
Trump mañana en un tribunal por su mal
manejo de los documentos clasificados
Anthony muy buenas noches cuéntenos Cuál
es ese proceso que se llevará a cabo
mañana en el tribunal Federal
Así es qué tal Muy buenas noches pues
efectivamente hay máxima expectación en
esta corte Federal donde se espera que
este martes alrededor desde las 2 de la
tarde llegue el expresidente Donald
Trump para esta comparecencia en esta
corte Federal es casi imposible que se
le vea acceder a estas instalaciones
porque va a entrar a través de un
estacionamiento subterráneo para después
tomarse las fotografías y las huellas
dactilares tampoco se sabe si va a ser
esposado antes de que de comienzo esta
audiencia después de eso en esa
comparecencia va a estar presente el
juez también la fiscalía los abogados de
Donald Trump Y por supuesto también el
ex mandatario ese era en ese momento
cuando se le van a leer formalmente los
37 cargos a los que deberá hacer frente
en este proceso Penal Federal hay que
recordar que 31 de esos 37 cargos
federales tienen que ver con la ley de
espionaje de Estados Unidos que es la
tiene que ver con la retención no
autorizada de información de defensa
nacional es decir cualquier tipo de
documento fotografía email que pudiese
ser utilizado en perjuicio de Estados
Unidos o En beneficio de cualquier país
extranjero hay que recordar que esos 31
documentos que se incautaron en la
residencia Privada de Mara lago aquí en
Florida estaban marcados como secretos o
Ultra secretos según los los expertos
penales dicen que este proceso A no ser
que se llegue a un acuerdo o se
desestime el juicio podría alargarse de
21 a 60 días es la segunda vez que el
presidente Donald Trump tiene que hacer
frente a la justicia en marzo tuvo que
presentarse en la corte de Manhattan
para el caso de los supuestos pagos a la
actriz porno stormy Daniels a cambio de
su silencio pero es la primera vez que
un ex mandatario de Estados Unidos tiene
que hacer frente a una corte Federal
Antonio ahora Cuál es la situación allí
en Florida en este momento había
declaraciones de las autoridades
previamente que decían que se estaban
preparando para posibles disturbios
cuéntenos
Sí de hecho
las autoridades del sur de la Florida
han preparado un dispositivo especial de
seguridad más de 1.400 agentes van a
estar desplegados por las inmediaciones
de esta corte Federal en colaboración
también con los agentes federales lo que
quieren evitar es que hayan disturbios
porque se espera que hayan
manifestaciones dice la policía de 5000
a 50.000 personas por eso no quieren
dejar nada al azar y que y mantener Todo
bajo control también sea acordonado ya
todo el acceso a esta corte Federal
precisamente para evitar en la medida de
lo posible los disturbios desde la
ciudad de Miami informan que no hay
planificada ningún tipo de manifestación
a pesar de que alertan que a través de
las redes sociales está haciendo un
llamado para la movilización